all right Jordan
where you from originally Albuquerque
New Mexico hmm yeah tell me about your
family
um so
I was born
to my father who is in the military or
was in the military he was actually an
F-16
mechanic so
like Top Gun when I watched Top Gun I
was thinking about him because he's like
I grew up hanging out with hangers it's
like F-16 fighter jets
and then
my mother my biological mother she's
hard of hearing so she's half deaf half
hearing
um they divorced when I was three years
old
and I have memories of them fighting
their relationship was tumultuous
because there was a lot of financial
struggles my dad was enlisted in the
military and
so he didn't we weren't making a lot of
money we were actually living in like my
grandpa's garage or something and then
when so I my earliest memories of them
fighting and like screaming and like
bad fights and it's very vague memories
because I was very young but they
divorced when I was three and then
when they got divorced
um it was just my dad and we I was in
daycare a lot a lot of time in daycare
alone
um
yeah I was a pretty defiant child I just
didn't want to listen to anyone I wanted
to do my own thing I think I didn't
trust anyone I used to have this
reoccurring dream of me being eaten by
wolves like which was like I don't know
I've talked about I've talked about it a
lot in therapy are you an only child
no I have an older I had an older
brother
um
at that time of my life he actually
passed away two years ago from an
overdose which is really sad we were all
really sad but then so when I my dad was
with my mother when there were three I
got divorced they got divorced
and then my dad remarried my stepmother
when I was eight and we were living in
Albuquerque New Mexico there's a
neighborhood called The War Zone which
is kind of like the Compton of
Albuquerque it was like
my dad it was just him and me and my
brother older brother and he we
struggled I remember lots of like butter
and pasta and garlic salt like we were
just really poor basically and we lived
in the war zone and then when my dad
married my stepmother when we were eight
years old we went and my dad had like
three jobs one I remember one year I
guess he saved his money for a year to
take my brother and I to Disney
Disneyland here and to Universal Studios
when we were before he married my
stepmom but when he married my stepmom
we went from in Albuquerque there's a
neighborhood called tanawan which is
like a gated community it would be like
the Bel Air of Albuquerque we went from
the like war zone to Bel Air and we had
like security guards and like a maid and
when I was eight so having that
awareness of like knowing
I was really poor and then now this is
this I was very aware of my
socio-economic status at a young age so
I was really insecure about
where we lived and I never wanted to
bring friends home to when my dad
married my stepmother I never brought
people over
I was always afraid to make friends I
felt really uncomfortable about our
where about not having things and then
having
things what kind of kid were you in high
school
in high school
I
in the beginning of my high school I so
before high school and middle school I
was all I was a dancer right when my dad
married my stepmother she was like oh
something's wrong with this kid because
I would like clung to her and they they
took me to psychiatrists and they put me
on like a cocktail medications like when
I was eight they put me on like Adderall
the psychiatrist put me on all these
meds because I was having ADHD problems
and I was doing dance so I I started
dancing and doing ballet
um when my dad married my stepmother she
took me to a show and I loved it and she
went and talked to the person in the
sound booth after and she asked them
my son really liked this show how can he
get involved and she happened to be the
director of the ballet company and so
why I bring this up before high school
is because before high school I was
doing dance I was doing I was doing
music I was in piano lessons I was doing
all this creative stuff my brother was a
football player and then I had a
stepsister I forgot to mention when my
dad married my stepmom and she was a
cheerleader and I was a dancer
and but what happened was in Middle
School I started getting bullied by all
the um
all the K the guys really all my friends
were girls I always felt like a girl in
a guy's body I never really felt like a
guy I all my friends were girls and but
I was bullied by all the guys they would
all call me [__] and I didn't know what
that meant
and then when I went to high school I
stopped doing all the dance all the
stuff I was trying to be cool so in high
school I was that's when I started
partying like a lot and drinking on the
weekends because in middle school is
when I started smoking weed and drinking
um with my friend on the weekend and in
high school I just I drank every weekend
um sometimes I I was supposed to go to
like this really nice
middle school and high school but I got
a really bad teacher recommendation
because I was really defiant I would
fight with my teachers I was always
dancing in class and the teachers didn't
like it and
so yeah I got sent to the principal's
office a lot
and then they sent me to a Catholics I
actually had to go to a Catholic school
for one year freshman year of college I
went to five high schools freshman
freshman year of high school they asked
me to leave because I got in trouble at
the Catholic school I ended up going to
a military school for one semester and
then I ended at this Christian school
but
it was I had a lot I was the type of
person that was friends with like
everyone I had like I did it wasn't a
part of one group I was friends with a
bunch of people
but I never considered myself a cool kid
I was kind of like weird and like I
don't know I didn't I wasn't very
popular I didn't get invited to a lot of
places I had a small group of friends I
kind of kept to myself and I was really
scared
um and I would get bullied by the jocks
and I was always attracted to them I
like wanted to hook up with them
but I did and one guy that I actually my
best friend made me do football
for one semester and I remember the the
wide receiver I had a big crush on hand
and I I'm the type of person who have a
crush on someone I'm not like damn
you're hot oh my God look at you I'm not
very vocal I'm I'm kind of shy so I
would just get really shy and quiet
around him and like get really nervous
and I think energetically he could tell
and it made him really uncomfortable and
one day after a game he just came up to
me and started beating me up like I just
said hi like and he's that was a
traumatic experience I had to work
through it's it made me really scared of
guys that I was attracted to so I I
started hooking up with guys when I was
in high school like and it was guys on
the internet like older guys like they
were like 20 years older than me and um
I told them I was 18 but there's no way
anyone believed me I did not look 18 at
all and I don't know I like the
attention and um
yeah but I I was always afraid to hook
up with or have sex with guys that I was
actually attracted to because I was
afraid that I wasn't good enough or that
I was ugly or too feminine or something
was wrong with me because of being uh
beat up by that football player but high
school was just me partying and living I
was not out of the closet I was living
like a double sex life like I was not
out yet so I had like a girlfriend who
was my best friend
and then I was hooking up with guys on
the internet like all of high school I
lived a double life like everyone
publicly knew I was gay because I was
very feminine and I was like every
girl's best friend
but like I I wasn't comfortable with it
and I was living this double
sex life pretty much just hooking up
with guys on the internet like all the
guys until like
eight years ago maybe six years ago the
youngest guy I'd ever been with was like
32 and I was like 14. like I hadn't been
with I was always with guys that were
way older than me
I was too afraid of my peers like to be
intimate with them sexually or
vulnerably
what'd you do after high school
okay after high school I fortunately got
to go to University of Hawaii for one
year in Honolulu my parents
they have this program that makes it
affordable like you can pay in-state
tuition plus half if you're on the
western side of the United States so I
went to University of Hawaii Rainbow
Warriors
which was the perfect mascot for me
because I actually came out of the
closet freshman year of college when I
was 18 in Hawaii
I actually did I did my first photo
shoot out there and I had a weird MO
I had a creepy moment with this
photographer in Hawaii basically we did
a photo shoot on the beach and then he
like just started after the shoot he
like basically tried to get me to hook
up with him and I just ran like I ran
away from him and just ran I actually
didn't get the photos till like two
years later I had to like threaten him
with a lawsuit to like get the pictures
they were cute pigs but like that was me
I had a lot of weird situations with
photographers because I was trying to be
a model like when I was eight I've
always wanted to be a pop star I saw the
Britney videos and I wanted to do that I
saw Madonna and I wanted to do that I
saw Michael Jackson I wanted to do that
so that's why I was doing music and
piano and dance and in high school I
wrote my first song then when I was in
Hawaii freshman year of college was when
Lady Gaga became famous it was 2009 and
when I saw her performing I was like I
can do that I can sing I can play the
piano I can dance I can I still I
started writing this show freshman year
of college called I called it Atlas and
I was trying to like compete with her
because it was Lady Gaga's monsters and
Atlas is aliens and I started drawing
all these crazy costumes I changed all
my social name social media names to
atlas
everyone thought I had gone crazy and I
got off my medication freshman year of
college and because I was out of my
parents like grasp and I was like I'm
gonna be off my meds and I just got
crazy freshman year of college Hawaii is
like the 80s it's just like a giant
party I was blacking out all over the
the city I was dating drug dealers like
I was on every drug cocaine I did a lot
of cocaine a lot of drugs I was just
really crazy partying all over Hawaii
blacking out waking up in
rooms with strangers like it was really
crazy and it's amazing that I got
through that period of my life but
um I started Dan the one good thing
about freshmere college is I started
dancing again because high school I had
stopped I always say that my drug
addiction and my partying in high school
it took precedence over my heart and
soul and my passion and my music and my
dancing because as soon as I stopped
dancing and singing is when I started
really doing a lot of drugs and partying
and freshman year college I was still
partying but I started doing dance and
music again I started writing songs and
drawing these costumes and I actually
dropped out of University of Hawaii
and moved to LA right after that but I
also came out of the closet in Hawaii I
had a scare I hooked up with this guy
um
two things happened in Hawaii that I got
I had the scare with this guy that I had
hooked up with I don't think we even
really had like full-on sex but a month
later he emailed me to say
whatever it is you have whatever you you
got like you need to go get tested and I
was actually getting sick at the time I
was getting like a cold and I was
coughing
and so I started I was like oh my God
what do I have so I started Googling the
symptoms of like HIV and I had all the
symptoms so and it was back before they
had the rapid test
so I had convinced myself I had HIV I
started that's when I came out of the
closet on Facebook I was like I'm gay do
you guys still love me I like boys or I
like guys and then I called my stepmom
crying I was like I have HIV I'm gonna
die like I was so dramatic and they were
so scared she was like I don't care if
you're gay or straight you can only have
sex with the amount of fingers on your
hand and I was like well we're way past
that so
anyways so I thought I had HIV for two
weeks and then the results came in and
it was negative and I all basically it
was bronchitis
so like in a way it was a blessing
because I started really starting to
reel myself in and being questioning who
am I like I would stare at myself in the
mirror for hours and be like who is this
person
it was just I was really really really
really lost but I didn't know it and
then and then I moved to LA right
shortly after that to pursue my dreams
to be an artist Superstar
pop star but the other thing that
happened in Hawaii that I didn't mention
yet is I started doing sex work because
my parents I was too scared to ask my
parents for my more money for vocal
lessons
and I was dating this guy who told me
he knows how he could get me 200 extra
dollars
like which wasn't a lot but he was like
you just go hang out with this guy and
he'll give you 200 and I just remember
going to this guy's Penthouse in Waikiki
and um
I
got really uh drunk and he gave me 200
dollars
and then I I didn't think I actually did
get some vocal lessons from that so my
first those were my first private vocal
lessons but I had been singing for a
while and then the next week he wanted
his he wanted to watch my boyfriend have
sex with me basically and um
he um he basically
um I don't know I didn't like how my
boyfriend was treating me so I got up
and like pushed him and I was like no I
don't want to be here and I called my
dad crying
um but those are the two things that
happened freshman year for me was I
started doing sex work and I came out of
the closet how long were you doing sex
work
up until
six years ago when I got sober I'm now
I'm six years sober from drugs and
alcohol I actually got court ordered
to go to 12-step programs seven years
ago because I got arrested in a blackout
in West Hollywood
um and I knew that if I didn't stop
doing sex work I wouldn't stay sober
because I would always get really high
and drunk
with my clients and I I was doing it so
when was that so I that was 2009 when I
started and I ended in 2016 so like
seven years and I didn't know
the thing about sex work for me it was
really empowering it made me feel like I
was in control that I was taking care of
business it gave me like the feeling of
being an entrepreneur you know I was I I
would make appointments with my clients
I took it seriously I wasn't the best
sex worker I think I could have charged
a lot more I was like way too cheap
according to charging well it I was so
towards the end I was doing massages so
I had like I would charge like a hundred
fifty dollars for an hour massage and
then I would charge like per service on
top of that like a hundred dollars more
for this fifty dollars more for this but
some of my friends I had a lot so I had
a community I had friends like all my
friends were sex workers and I my I had
his boyfriend he was like a coke dealer
I was like in that world like all my
friends were dealers prostitutes
gangsters one of my exes was like Al
Capone's grandson it's like but it's not
like he was like some crazy gangster he
was like classy like he was very like
romantic and like he would get me like
really nice cards and like anyway he was
crazy but I feel bad I was
totally using that guy it was a awful
situation anyway so
so I should have charged more because
some of my friends they were making like
ten thousand dollars for the weekend to
go to Japan with some of their clients
and one of my friends made a hundred
thousand dollars the first gear of
prostitution I think I had a lot of
insecurity and I didn't know my value
fully
and I I didn't know how
to ask for more I didn't know I deserved
for more my parents I told you when we
moved from the get the hood to the nice
neighborhood
my parents kind of made us believe we
were still poor like I had to get a job
when I was 14. my first job was at this
amusement park and they made me buy my
own clothes they made me like
my neighbors like one of my neighbors
started learning to drive in a Ferrari
like that's the kind of neighborhood
like her dad was teaching her how to
drive in a Ferrari and my parents like
gave me this old shitty like Toyota
Camry like they they I thought like
mentally I was all [__] up financially
I didn't know
I didn't understand my value and like my
worth
and I just sold myself way too short so
basic I would make like 200 to 300 per
client but that was like for an hour's
work
so it was really hard to stop sex work
because I was addicted to the Fast Cash
and like the thrill I loved you know I
love sex like sex is fun and like there
was a time before I got sober that whole
year before I got sober I would not have
sex for free like I wouldn't like if I
was going to hook up with someone I
would make them pay me like I was just
Savage I was so broken sometimes you
make that connection of with sex and
money yeah it's hard to separate them it
was really hard to separate because
well because it made me feel like I was
in control like my experience was those
seven years is
I called I had this thing called the
single [__] Club
and when I wasn't dating someone or
committed to someone I could do whatever
the [__] I want and I would it sex work
included that because I would stop doing
sex work when I had a crush on someone
because I thought that they would take
care of me I thought that they would
provide for me I'd I would stop
everything when I had a crush on someone
and then when it would end I would get
all sad and heartbroken and then I would
just start doing sex work again so for
me like it was
when I was doing sex work it felt like I
was providing for myself I was taking
care of me I was doing what I needed to
do and in a way I was and so there's a
part I'm very grateful for the
experience that I've had as a sex worker
like it's made me really strong it's
made me really smart it's kind of like
[__] me up though because 90 of my
clients were straight which I don't
really believe if these guys are married
or they were married they had children I
never asked questions but I knew like I
could see the wedding ring and I could
see the pictures on their phones and we
would always meet in hotel rooms it's
actually hard like
it's every time I'm in a hotel I think
about it like I go into euphoric recall
I had a job at the Mondrian for three
months like last year
and it was really hard every time I
would just deliver ice to the to a guest
at the hotel I would go into euphoric
recall what is euphoric recall euphoric
recall is when you feel like you're
having this experience from the past
because it was such a high for me so
you're going up to deliver ice to room
12 17. and I would feel like I was going
to go see a client or are about to hook
up with someone because it was such a
high for me I would get so high because
it's sex it's money like
and then when I was working at the
Mondrian which is like not super high
paying job that's the other thing is I
went six years ago from like making 300
in one hour to making that in two weeks
so it was so [__] hard like these
last six years have been so hard it's
been a lot of I've been on food stamps
EBT Obama phone like how old are you now
I'm 31. 31 and I got sober when I was
25 and it's been really hard to dig
myself out of this [__] hole that
I've been in and it's gotten in the way
of my music career my I really believe
if I put as much drive into sex work and
to the drug use that I was doing
I feel like into my music career I feel
like I'd be like super Famous by now I'd
be like a big time artist and I've been
able to get a lot more done since I've
gotten sober like my I've hosted a lot
of shows my shows before sobriety when I
was using because I was always high so
it's like
they were always a hot mess like I would
the the lights would go out then this
the my wigs were [__] ugly and like I
just was such a mess at least I was
doing it though you know I think it's
good that I was because there's a
there's a learning curve when you're
starting any new business and I was high
when I was doing it I really wish
if I could go back in time I really wish
I never started doing all the drugs and
the prostitution I really wish I knew my
own value and
put as much effort into
my my hustle as in the music industry
because now I struggle with finding my
value and my worth as an artist and I'm
trying to put my mind towards my music
and career but part of me still believes
that all I have to offer is my sexuality
my body my and it's hard for me to
figure out how to Market myself
because of my voice or because of this
or because of that it's gotten in the
way and there's a lot of very attractive
people in the entertainment industry so
like that whole thing about me being
scared of guys that I'm attracted to
not everything's about sex some of these
guys that I should talk to it's about
business it's about music it's about
collaborating but it's because of my
trauma as a sex worker
everything sort of becomes about sex and
it's gotten in the way of me networking
in the music industry but I'm getting
you know every day I get better I talk
about things I'm going through I have a
big support network of people in
recovery and out of recovery that I'm
honest with I've learned how to ask for
help like I ask people for advice now
that's a huge thing I didn't trust
anyone before I got sober so I was
always afraid to ask anyone for help
so I never like I just kept digging
myself deeper and deeper into this hole
and I was in like sixty thousand dollars
worth of debt because I had two
repossessed cars and
I was homeless for six months living in
my car like because I was trying to make
an album and I was putting all my money
into the album
it was a hard hard time to between 2009
and 2016 when I got sober I was living
on people's couches see I was making so
much money as a sex worker but I could
not afford to pay rent did you were
spending it on drugs I was spending it
on drugs
I was spending it on clothes
I don't know like it's weird like I
don't know where that money goes I don't
know where like even just like try to
even the female sex workers I've
interviewed they're all next to broke
they're surviving day by day even though
they're making a thousand bucks a day
yeah I I am to this day baffled because
I made so much money but I couldn't I
never had a place to live I was still
starving myself
just I mean I'm not someone that eats a
lot gen anyway and you didn't have a
pimp yeah and I didn't have a pan I
didn't I did it all by myself I would
just but you still found a way to burn
through all the money yeah it's weird
it's it's bad it's like this how much
money you did empty on average
well towards the end I was seeing four
to five guys a day like when I was in
New York so it's well over a thousand
yeah and
I don't know where that money went it's
so weird to me I it's so weird to me
because I was I didn't have rent to pay
I don't know where that money went
I really don't like it's it's baffling
to me it's I feel like
whoa like it's like
dysphoric trying to think about where it
went probably on clothing I it's fast
money and shoes and
I don't it comes fast it goes fast yeah
alcohol
food
but yeah I I tried to have some normal
jobs in that that time and now these
last six years because of my experience
there's I've learned from sober
recovering sex workers
that there's a thing called post
prostitution syndrome it's a thing and
it's we all have some similar situations
and it's obvi it's like Diva problems
because we don't know how to like I had
to have someone simply explain to me you
need to get eight hours of sleep every
night you need to eat every four hours
like eat something and then I had to
have people explain to me like how to
live like healthily and I still struggle
with it sometimes like what are the post
prostitution
it's things like like
problems with authority figures
um and then a lot of the sex euphoric
recall with
with guys like making everything sexual
insecurity when it comes to like dating
guys and being with people
um
that and I don't know there's a whole
list if you Google it it's all on Google
but I also have learned in recovery that
I think a large part of my
sex work and fear of my value comes from
my mother being deaf and hard of hearing
because when I was little I'd be crying
for my needs and my mom wouldn't hear me
right away so I would be like in the
crib for like 30 minutes before she came
to me and brought me but she still
didn't really understand me so I I have
a lot of things that I've worked through
in therapy and EMDR
um and then I've done the 12 Steps like
several times and my life just keeps
getting better every day and I'm
actually really grateful for this any
opportunity to tell my story because
there were times like when I was nearly
sober where like it was so hard it was
like so hard to get just through another
day and the only thing that I had
sometimes was my story
that that was the only thing I had of
value to go to a 12-step meeting and
tell my story and connect with other
people and other
other guys and girls and tell my story
because they would relate to me and I
would relate to them and there's
something really empowering about
hearing my story in another person and
it's helped me heal like hearing other
people's stories and sharing my story
has been the biggest part of my healing
process so I encourage anyone that's
struggling like anywhere to find someone
to talk to and just someone that'll
listen without judgment
whether it be at a 12-step meeting or
somewhere and just tell your story like
or hear like with
that soft white underbelly are you
happier now that you're walking
Australia path
it's hard because I'm not using drugs
and alcohol and I'm trying not to use
sex even to numb myself of the pain or
when I'm in fear I'm about to go on this
three-month Adventure in Europe
and I'm so [__] scared I have so much
fear there's like I feel like I'm
walking in the dark because I've never
been to Europe I'm going by myself I
don't have a lot of money saved we're
doing doing things that scare you a
little bit Yeah and before like drugs
and alcohol would give me that liquid
courage
I I was the life of the party I was the
person dancing on the the tables I was
the person talking to everyone like
flirting with anyone I thought was cute
everyone thought I was Fearless but it
was just because I was high as [__] and
my goal in recovery so it's it's hard
like
I the moments where I'm peaceful and
Serene in recovery are amazing it's
Blissful it's better than anything drugs
or alcohol could provide for me because
it's peaceful it's real but the moments
that are hard when I'm scared and in
fear like right now
or like when I'm I used to use the first
time I had an audition I got high on
liquid codeine and it helped me get
through my nerves of the audition and I
I acet audition and got into that show
now when I'm nervous or scared I can't
take codeine I can't take I mean I can I
have the choice to but I choose not to
so I have to rely on other tools that
aren't as quick of a fix like talking to
someone I pray a lot meditation really
helps me journaling but it's not
something that like just taking a sip of
codeine or alcohol or taking a hit or a
line is gonna do instantaneously
sometimes prayer has that effect on me
and meditation where it does it really
fast but
it's a lot harder when I'm in pain
I really really feel things now before
recovery I numbed out all my feelings
that's what I think is really at the
root of a lot of the stories you see on
my channel is
people are dealing with emotionally
uncomfortable situations and the alcohol
the drugs the pot the whatever will help
them deal
but what happens is you get so used to
using those substances that you end up
addicted to them and then your life
unravels I agree with you 100 like the
other night my friend and I were looking
through my Facebook and it keeps you
from Material what's that and it also
keeps you from maturing because part of
maturing is being able to deal with
emotionally different my growth was
stunted I feel like a child in an
adult's body that's how I feel like
emotionally I'm getting better every day
I'm way more mature now than I was seven
years ago but there's things that I
didn't learn in high school and middle
school because I was too busy trying to
party and I was I was fighting with my
parents a lot and so I didn't learn a
lot of the things that I needed to learn
and um yeah you're very intuitive about
that I really agree with you about
um it's not intuition it's six thousand
interviews yeah
evidence yeah and I I the thing is like
I um
I think I was heartbroken as a child and
so scared because of my parents divorce
when they were three it's just intrinsic
human nature Behavior to be territorial
we're packed creatures my mother and
father divorced I was mean to all my
dad's girlfriends and all my mother's
boyfriends I was so mean to them it's
because I'm a kid I'm territorial it's
human nature to keep my caretakers
together so I can survive so I I was
terrified I was heartbroken the guys
being gay being bullied I was just
bottled up and I didn't know to talk
about anything I was arrested towards
the end of my drinking because I was an
angry drunk towards the end of my
drinking I would get in fights with
people I would argue with people I would
make fun of people like I got in a fight
at Fiesta Cantina in West Hollywood with
the security guards because they were
like kicking me out I was in my
underwear it was Halloween and I was a
stripper Sim so all I was wearing was
like this thong and like a sim hat and I
got arrested in that outfit so on my
cards all it said was items worn was
like a speedo and I refused to tell them
my name so it said like John Doe
anyway so I I was so broken and sad and
lost and just stuck in this little ball
and I didn't know how to feel everything
so now that I'm sober I've had to go
through all these steps and therapy to
just get out everything that I've been
through as a child and talk about it and
share about it and relate to people and
I feel all those emotions all this
unprocessed grief I'm like it's all
coming out of me like a volcano
and it's all out but I still feel it
sometimes and uh and now I just have now
I really really feel things so when I'm
sad I really feel sad when I'm angry I
really feel angry when I'm happy I
really feel happy but before recovery I
was it was all convoluted I I it was all
blurred together like all my emotions
and um I didn't understand where they're
coming from and it's gotten a lot better
I'm not as reactive I got my anger
management my anger got worse when I got
sober and I got real I would get and
really get really mad at people when I
was because you didn't know how to deal
with your
yeah emotions I didn't know how to deal
with it I wasn't numbing myself of all
the pain anymore so
it's been a hard journey it's not easy
but life isn't easy and and the things
still happen like I'm still my brother
died two years ago I'm still struggling
financially I'm still trying to get my
[__] together
as a musician as an artist but I'm not
resetting every day with drugs and
alcohol instead I'm like praying I'm
meditating I'm talking to people I'm
asking for advice I trust people now so
I'm reaching out to people asking for
help before I was trying to do
everything on my own
and you know it takes a it takes a a
village to make it all the big
Superstars artists
they have huge teams around them what
does that tell you these people know how
to work with other people so I know that
I need to learn how to work with other
people doing prostitution was a solo
Journey for me I didn't even have a pimp
I was doing everything on my own and
then I was applying that to my music
career I was being my manager and my
marketer I was doing everything on my
own it was a one-man show and it wasn't
going anywhere so I'm still learning day
by day how to open myself up how to
bring people into my life and it's a
struggle I haven't really dated anyone's
I've since I've gotten sober
I've hooked up with a few people here
and there but I'm still healing I'm
still
getting my [__] together but doing stuff
like this I really hope sharing my story
helps someone else and I hope that it
helps you and I'm really grateful that
you're letting me tell my story it was a
great story thank you very much Jordan
thank you wish you all the luck in the
world thank you have fun in Europe yes